dot org
and book tv's coverage of the miami book
fair continues now with miami herald
investigative reporter julie k brown who
discusses her in-depth look into the
jeffrey epstein criminal case this
program will get underway shortly
[Music]
hello good evening and welcome to the
38th edition of the miami book fair
and my name is patrick nellis i work
here at the college in the center for
learning and it's my pleasure to get us
started for this evening i have a couple
of announcements uh
so one is that the book fair doesn't
just end tonight it carries on
throughout the year we've got events all
over town and live streaming and so on
so stay in touch with
the miami book fair on the web
furthermore we need to acknowledge the
hundreds of volunteers that make this
event possible and our major sponsors
without whom we could not run the book
fair the knight foundation the bachelor
foundation the meredith ann dasberg
foundation the green family foundation
stephanie anson and stewart's spencer
stewart t-mobile and many other sponsors
i also need to do this every time can we
see a show of hands of the friends of
the book fair
great and let's give yourselves a round
of applause for being friends of the
book fair
the book fair needs friends
find out about the perks of joining us
as a friend of the book fair we have a
table downstairs i have a couple of
announcements one is please try to make
your phone quiet so it doesn't interrupt
and
we will take questions and answers
towards the end of the presentation we
have a microphone in the middle of the
room and we'll ask you to line up and uh
one question per customer so that people
can get an opportunity following the
talk the author
uh julie brown will be
at the author's signing desk
past on this floor past the elevators
i'll be escorting her down there after
the talk and you can purchase her book
at the table outside
of the room with this i'm going to
introduce our
our master ceremonies for this evening
who's going to introduce the speaker
this is maria meyer she's the interim
executive director of the women's fund
miami-dade
as one billion rising global coordinator
for miami she's worked with activists
across the u.s
to create the awareness and solidarity
necessary to end
the staggering statistics of gender
violence maria is a member of the south
florida human trafficking task force
and miami-dade human
trafficking coalition
so much
good evening to all here present
whether virtually or in this auditorium
i'm maria meyer very proudly
representing your women's fund
miami-dade and our mutual supporters of
the book fair and of the women's fund
from the shepherd broad foundation
together tonight we will focus here on
power
power of one writer's proverbial pen
the power of narcissism and unmitigated
privilege
and the power of investigative
journalism to focus a critical
magnifying lens
long and hard enough on the facts to
spark the collective outrage necessary
to leverage action
miami herald investigative journalist
julie k brown relentlessly pursued how
jeffrey epstein's years-long engagement
in exploitation and sex trafficking
remained unchecked
for decades he freely moved through high
society and political circles
leaving more and more survivors in his
wake
her version of justice shines a
spotlight on these crimes and long-time
avoidance of any real consequences
not legal not financial nor personal
it's a fascinating and in-depth look at
a gross miscarriage of justice
as director of the knight foundation's
journalism program karen redlett's
philanthropic focus is on investing in
new methods to advance excellence in
journalism and civic media
as a way to support informed local
communities
and that is what is about to happen here
please join me in welcoming her and
author julie k brown to the miami book
fair stage
hi julie hi hi everyone thank you so
much for coming tonight
um
let's get started by
um julie and i used to work together at
the miami herald um
but i'm not sure that
everyone knows her very well and also
there's quite a bit in this book that i
learned about her so
why don't we start by learning a little
bit about you um
so let's just start with where are you
from how'd you grow up
how'd you end up in journalism
um
thank you all for coming by the way um
it's good to be back in person at the
book fair
um
i
i grew up in a little tiny town outside
of philadelphia called sellersville
and um
you know my mother was a single mom with
three children and
needless to say we struggled quite a bit
and i think instilled in me some of the
things my mother went through as a
single mom i remember one time we came
home and all the furniture was gone from
our house because my mother couldn't pay
a utility bill
so
you know just the
you know
injustices that i felt that she suffered
um sort of instilled in me i think at a
young age that i wanted to do something
about it
so that's kind of led me into writing
writing was an outlet for me when i was
very young
uh and
you know that the fact that you know i
would read you know stories about
great um people and how they overcame
obstacles in their lives and i think
that that made me also want to write you
know stories about people like that or
to in some way make a difference in
other people's lives
so you started your career career in
philadelphia
and uh what what was that like what were
you writing about what were you
reporting on
well i started actually in hunterdon
county i worked for every small paper
that you could ever imagine i started
really at the bottom you know doing
obituaries which are actually very good
training ground actually
because you have to learn everything
about a person and tell this story about
them in a very respectful way so i i
just really
went up the ladder you know and um in
the beginning i mean i couldn't support
myself on journalism salary and
i worked as a waitress you know sort of
like actors do starving actors i was
starving journalists so i worked a
couple of jobs just to kind of pay the
rent and
you know and then i finally got a big
break when i was hired by the
philadelphia daily news which was a
metropolitan big metropolitan newspaper
in philadelphia and you know then moved
to the big city
and then you eventually ended up in
south florida
yeah so
um you were an editor for a while and
you talk about that in the book and then
you eventually went back to reporting
why don't you tell us about
what it takes to be a reporter how do
you get your stories you reported on
prisons for a number of years
well i i did a lot of
you know i always felt like one of the
ways that i could stay in this business
was to make sure that i could do
everything i could learn a little bit
about everything and um
so i just tried to be very nimble you
know and just every time they asked me
to do something i said yes because i
feared i would be able to keep my job if
i if i uh worked hard enough and just
never argued so and at least in the
beginning of my uh
career i didn't argue a lot and i did
everything i was told to do that of
course as i became more experienced i
started arguing more but
but um
yeah it was um
you know i did you know
running after murder scenes in the worst
neighborhoods of philadelphia
going to fires in the middle of the
night car crashes i mean
probably almost everything i i've done
at one time or another
but i really like the crime
i really kind of got a niche with
covering crime and then from crime i
realized um you know that the police
didn't always do a good job
of investigating and so i realized that
i could find out things that the police
didn't even know and that's sort of
that's when i got the bug to be to do
more investigative work
so again you had been working covering
women's prisons and done really
exceptional work but you were looking
for something else and um how did you
really find this story what is it that
you first saw that made you really want
to go deeper
what shocked you
well you know this was an old story i
didn't
contrary to what some people often um
say i didn't break the jeffrey epstein's
story this had happened a decade before
i took it up and it did get a lot of
coverage in certain places um
particularly in palm beach at the time
that it happened originally
but it didn't get much traction
nationally and i think it kind of
dropped off the radar after everybody
just kind of concluded that jeffrey
epstein got off or got this very lenient
sentence because he was very wealthy and
that's just the way our system works
and i felt that
you know
that's not a good enough reason you know
i felt like there was more to it i
always suspected that there was some
kind of corruption involved in it
and then when donald trump was nominated
i'm sorry when donald trump was running
for president
a woman had filed a lawsuit against him
and jeffrey epstein claiming that he had
actually assaulted her
along with jeffrey epstein as well so
you know there was an article that i
read in in a newspaper where they were
sort of taking the mainstream media to
task for not looking into
um this whole story about epstein and
trump and this woman
and i
you know i had already known about the
case and i thought this does seem weird
maybe i should take a look so as i was
sort of starting to pick away at looking
at the case
trump got elected and then he nominated
alex acosta as labor secretary and i
knew that alex acosta was the
person who had signed off on this
sweetheart plea deal that epstein
received so i
thought at the time like i wonder what
these
victims who were young you know 13 14
years old at the time now they're in
their late 20s i wonder what they think
about the fact that the man that swore
you know pretty much let their predator
off the hook
was now in charge of a large agency with
oversight on human trafficking and child
labor laws
so
my initial goal was just to try to see
if the victims would finally come
forward and talk to me but as i started
digging more and more into the story i
found
you know so much more there was so much
more to the story the the victims how
they were treated but also how epstein
managed to manipulate just about every
part of this case
and and the prosecutors kind of looked
the other way as he was doing it or
relented
continually and let him get away with it
the thing about the the reporting is it
really looked at the entire system and
you talked a lot you speak about that a
lot you wrote about that a lot in the
book um just
the different uh
the different uh he would he would hire
um attorneys that were married to other
attorneys and so then somebody would be
eliminated there was conflict of
interest
um
so tell me a little bit about the
process you know investigative reporting
there's a mystery around it and there's
also
you you spend time digging into records
and it doesn't necessarily
turn something up or sometimes you go
down too many rabbit holes why don't we
get into the process of the work that
you did
well you know no one just wakes up one
day and decides to be an investigative
reporter uh you know there are a lot of
reporters that don't like doing
investigative work
there's a lot of reporters that do great
journalism
um in a certain like business journalism
or or aspects of um
you know journalism that i couldn't do
you know and somehow i mean you have to
you know my kind of i think the thing
that led me to do investigative
journalism is because i just always
wanted to get to the truth you know
and i felt like um there was so much
going on in our country and in society
where i thought sometimes
we just really don't know how this
happened like how this
particular person ended up in this
particular place
and that always fascinated me and all
often when i looked into it there was
always a story you know and that's what
we do even though it's a lot of digging
it's also about telling stories because
that's what makes people interested so
you have to
your work is kind of twofold in that you
have to um
you know dig through these dense
horribly boring documents you know that
are written by people like lawyers and
it's the last thing sorry any lawyers
here sorry maybe yours but you got to
kind of make sense out of it and you
know it isn't really easy to do that and
in this particular case there was
tens of thousands of documents
you know that had been filed over the
years because after the criminal case
ended there were all these civil
lawsuits that were filed so
you know like a dozen civil lawsuits and
you know each one of them had like you
know 200 docket entries you know in this
system so
i realized at first i thought when i did
it i thought i could do what i always do
which is usually what a reporter does is
they take the motion for summary
judgment you know the complaint the
motion for summary judgment you know the
key documents that you know where
they're laying out their case and then
you can write a story off of that but i
quickly realized that it wasn't gonna
work in this case because i would read
something in the for example in the
motion for summary judgment i'm like
what
where'd they get that and then i thought
i've got a you know and then i'd go to
that document and then that document
would i would be like
there's no way i'm sort of
cherry-picking documents i said i've got
to sit down i got to read every single
thing because
by doing that i was able to put
take this story apart and put it back
together in a way i think that other
people hadn't been able to do so how
long did that take you
it took me a good year and a half
to read all those documents and some
there were there were documents that you
couldn't get access to
that you needed the herald to help you
get right
fortunately um and you know i i should
have mentioned uh the herald um a lot
sooner because i couldn't have really
done this without the support of the the
herald um especially since investigative
reporting by the way is the most costly
thing that a newspaper does
imagine you know your
you know one of the ways for example
that people get around
giving you
public documents is by charging a lot
for them so you'll say i want this
investigation on a copy of it and
they'll say well it's five thousand
dollars you know and then you gotta
negotiate with them and maybe you only
get half of it or you only get the first
10 pages or you only get the summary but
it is very expensive to do investigative
work and that's why you should buy
newspapers because you're only paying
you know i don't know what it is now i
paid 10 a month for the online version
but you know
buying these documents that we buy that
you would never otherwise have
access to is part of what goes into the
price of the newspaper you know that's
actually in your twitter bio you said
real journalism costs money please buy a
newspaper
um so
you know they're really highs and lows
there there are times where you're
you're you're digging deep and um
[Music]
you're
not finding things
um and there are times where you are
they're just some highs so
tell me uh in the in the reporting
process in this year and a half what was
a moment that was a big win and you knew
you were able to advance this and what
was the moment that was really difficult
well the most challenging part of this
case was finding the victims because
you know now they were in their late 20s
some of them had gotten married you know
others had gone to jail um there was you
know
they were first of all all their names
were redacted from the documents because
they were minor minors so how do you
find out who these women even are so
you know what i learned you know with
all the experience that i had by this
point was that inevitably when you get
these uh files that are redacted they
forget to redact things
so you know you might get a first name
accidentally unredacted here or a
birthdate and i just put together a big
spreadsheet with everything i knew about
each of the victims and when it was all
said and done i had a list of 60 women
and
then you have to try to contact them and
so that was probably the biggest
challenge
that i had was and that took a long time
finding them and and in the process of
doing that in order to find them i had
to find out a little bit about them
and i recognized a pattern with these uh
young women that their lives
had been dramatically
altered by what had happened to them you
know the abuse that they suffered you
know a lot of them had
fallen into drug addiction
or had ended up in jail um some of them
had were victims of domestic you know
abuse
um so i could see right away that this
was you know that these victims really
suffered an awful lot of pain in the
years that followed so um the story just
kind of morphed into his you know
originally going to be just a reaction
to
acosta being nominated and his victims
saying what they thought about it to
me realizing that this was a total
utter failure on the part of the
criminal justice system in a horrible
way
and so
you know and then you know you have to
kind of talk your editor into
letting you do more and to pay more and
that was a breeze right it was easy your
editor just said yes to everything i'm
sure yeah just do it these five stories
first
you know uh
so yeah it's it's it's you know i was
doing covering a hurricane in the middle
of this um we had um it was quite a
parkland parkland happened in the middle
of this and of course we dropped
everything and you know i was up there
doing stories in parkland so you know
you don't just
you know stop doing all the other work
that we have to do
um and i like i like doing that i like
going back and forth actually i think it
gives you a fresh perspective when you
um kind of break away for for a little
while and then go back to it and then
you realize oh my gosh i still have so
much work to do
so and you you worked with a partner you
worked with emily michonne yes emily i
think emily is here somewhere oh yes
there she is um
yes i could not have done this without
emily she um
she's kind of my guiding force
because i could go off the rails
sometimes so uh yes and you know
her work um on the visual part of this
we did a number of documentaries that
accompanied the series which were
interviews with the victims and they in
my view were really the most powerful
part of the whole entire project because
this was
you know i i say now because the story
is now an international story and every
journalist in the world is practically
on this story but and i i say this all
the time to emily no one will ever
capture the rawness that emily captured
and i'm getting chills just thinking
about it um
because those nobody had cared about
what those girls thought before we met
them and
you know to be there when they were
talking about it for the first time in a
decade
and the emotions that poured out of them
um
nobody's ever going to capture that the
way that emily did and um so that i
would encourage anybody to go online and
and see the documentaries because they
were really a very very if not the most
important part
of the project and you know when you
said what was the moment when you knew
the moment that we knew was when we
interviewed the first victim and i still
get teary every time i talk about it
because it was just a moment that we
knew we had such a good and important
story and
we just knew you know that was a big
breakthrough
so the story was published
sorry
take a moment yeah go ahead sorry
so the story was published november 28th
um
2018.
um it's november 21st today
three
so
ago yeah three years ago um and
at this point three years ago um
you were being lawyered those lawyers
again
um
lawyers are reviewing everything
including
the videos the documentary videos that
um emily worked on with you
and um
what's happening i there's something
happened on thanksgiving day well emily
was making pies because we just talked
about this because she's we're almost
thanksgiving i said are you gonna be
making pies with her family and the
lawyers were working on it over the
holiday because it was supposed to run
that next weekend and
they called her and told her she had to
rework one of the whole videos so she
had to drop everything and she went she
reworked the whole thing like a trooper
of course she called me screaming and
yelling but
but um
yeah
it's just what we do you know
it's um it's just very challenging work
but it's very important work and i think
if you keep your eye on what the goal is
um
you kind of push through it you know all
the challenges all the arguments with
the editors and
you know
you know the resources the lack of
resources the fact that they you know
they don't want to
you know pay for this or pay for that
and it's just it's hard sometimes but
you you know you just take deal with it
you know like a professional
so i would love for you to read from the
book
exactly what happened on the day that
you published i know that
you were hoping that
it would be a splash for a day if you
were lucky
so i would love it if you would read um
that section okay page 276.
story was published uh online and uh
yeah they put the whole series out
online um right away on um
i think it was a thursday
and i went in real early that morning
because i knew it was gonna launch and
we were gonna do a lot of social media
on it
and
you know
your exhaust i was absolutely exhausted
because um you know we had been editing
it for weeks and working on the video
and
you just at the point where you just
want it to be all over
i want this to be done i want to go home
and go to bed
so
that
the launch time for the online version
of the story kept changing but we
finally finally landed on november 28th
at 7 00 am
i went home that night and tossed in bed
unable to sleep i finally gave up and
got up about 4 00 am
i headed to the gym at five and climbed
on the elliptical trainer
i remember praying the entire time i was
on the machine that my story would at
least last one day online before being
forgotten
i went home showered threw on jeans and
a t-shirt and drove to the doral
newsroom just after dawn
i stopped and bought 60 dollars worth of
bagels and coffee for the crew that
morning hoping i had enough money in my
bank account to cover the expense
when i walked into the newsroom i looked
at the large digital screen in the
center of the room that lists the
herald's most read stories that morning
at the top of the list was a story about
a woman who had farted in a dollar store
the headline was woman passes gas in
store then pulls knife
it was getting thousands of hits
i almost never paid attention to the
stories at the top of the board they
were often click bait that we in other
newspapers use to lure our readers to
the other more serious journalism on our
website
at about 8 a.m the three parts of the
series along with the massive grass
graphic all the videos a timeline and a
piece called how we got the story were
launched under the headline
how a future trump cabinet member gave a
serial sex abuse abuser the deal of a
lifetime
i began tweeting out the stories
i hardly had any followers on twitter so
it was a short task
our two social media talents noel
gonzalez and adrian rui were busy
blitzing the stories across the internet
universe i had a bagel watch the board
with my stories at the very bottom of
the list then began packing up with the
intention of going home to sleep i was
relieved my work was done
the newsroom was starting to get busy as
more staff arrived for work
suddenly reporter rene rodriguez shouted
over have you seen the board
i walked over and my stories all three
of them were climbing fast the first one
had thousands of hits
well it's never going to top that fart
story i said walking back to my desk
before turning off my computer i looked
at my twitter account i suddenly had
thousands of followers
then the unbelievable happened
it beat the fart story
the room erupted in applause
my phone started ringing and my computer
mailbox was filling up with
congratulations
the first call i took was from mike
ritter
writer which i always mispronounced his
name writer he was more
he was more than elated
finally he said someone had put together
the epstein story in a way that would
make people understand the scope of his
crimes and worse how prosecutors helped
epstein get away with them
writer's words meant the world to me
that's it
[Applause]
so have you seen alex
acosta all
have you no
no not at all
i don't think anybody has seen him
actually yeah so i haven't had any
sightings let's put it that way
so um
[Music]
look this story it it has connections to
two former presidents it has connections
to a prince it has um
prestigious uh attorneys all over it
um
and
uh
coming up next week next week
after thanksgiving um there will be
another trial um there is a chapter in
here um
there is a chapter in the book about um
how this ended for jeffrey epstein and i
know that's something people always want
to know from you what do you think
happened
so what do you think happened
well i don't think he committed suicide
um i know a lot of people disagree with
that but uh i you know i covered prisons
for a long time and i know the way that
corruption happens
and this was a textbook case of
you know a suspicious death
and um there were just too many holes in
the whole story i mean he uh you know he
had just come off a suicide watch he
you know they took the guy who was a
cellmate out just hours before this
allegedly happened he you know the two
you didn't just have one guard fall
asleep you had two guards fall asleep
the cameras weren't working um you know
they take the body remove the body
without even taking photographs i mean
it the whole thing
just it it just doesn't make any sense
coupled with the fact that epstein was
the kind of person that believed he was
above the law
he really had gotten away with this the
first time
and this was an old case
um he conceivably could claim that you
know the these charges were based on the
plea bargain that he had agreed to with
federal prosecutors in florida and
therefore he was already the charges
were already disposed of and he was only
in prison for like a month when he
allegedly committed suicide he was
hiring lawyers up until you know that
week he was hiring new lawyers so the
whole thing um
just doesn't make sense that he would
have done it to begin with but not only
that but done it by his own hand which
this was a man that didn't do anything
on his own you know he had you know
people practically tying his own
shoelaces you know and for him to break
three bones not one bone but three bones
in his neck and do it by somehow leaning
forward by tying something to the top
bunk
and he would do that it's just
it's just unfathomable to me that it
happened that way now do i think that
it's possible if he wanted to do himself
any he he probably would have hired
somebody to do it he wouldn't have he
wouldn't have done it i just don't think
he was capable of doing it on his own
so will you be covering the trial that's
upcoming for
elaine maxwell yeah yeah
yeah okay
um and um
we are going to open it up to
folks for questions as well so if you
have questions um
i am what are you what how are you
preparing for that how are you preparing
to report on that
yeah you know that's a really good
question this is going to be a real
challenge because it's going to be a
media circus and we're i'm probably
here's a real funny thing i can't get
press credentials
for this trial i can't get them
yeah
they won't give me press credentials
she's probably wouldn't be
trying she wouldn't be in jail right now
if it wasn't for me but i can't get
credentials because i'm not a new york
uh journalist so you have to be like a
new york journalist to get credentials
in the uh courthouse so i'm i'm just
praying that i'll be able to get in the
courtroom and
you know hope for the best you know
and um please if anyone if anyone does
want to ask questions we have a mic oh
hello
don't you go to the mic so if you can
line up in the middle and behind the mic
we'll go one person at a time one okay
hi thank you so much i'm very inspired
by all your hard work
and um
my question is are you
were you afraid of any threats of
retaliation and is there anything
that ever happened as a result i'm never
afraid emily is the one that kind of
makes me worry because she's the one
that has she's the voice of reason in
our team
because um i just
i just don't think about it until it's
pointed out to me like i would always
tell people
no i wasn't worried but now that you
bring it up now i'm worried you know um
you can't you know when i was covering
the prisons i was far more worried about
my safety than i was with this case
i was able to
essentially do this story under the
radar
jeffrey epstein had no idea what he was
what he was confronting he really didn't
know i mean we contacted him but i think
he just thought this is just some little
reporter from the miami herald and
what's she going to get that nobody else
hasn't already gotten so
uh you know i think that that worked to
my favor that i worked for a small local
a really small but a regional newspaper
and not the new york times if it was the
new york times knocking on his door as
much as i did he probably would have
paid closer attention to be honest with
you so no i i didn't really worry until
after the series ran and then we had a
couple of um
suspicious things happen which i'll have
to get my book and you'll have to read
it in my book
thank you
hi julie um
since
you believe
and so did the guy who destroyed the
the painting at uh
basil last year
uh
that he didn't commit suicide
uh are you gonna are you gonna track and
see what happens see
if you can find out
you know you know what i don't know how
much of this how much of my life should
i dedicate to this story
you know there's so many other stories
you know i in my mind this story was one
that people you know that had been
forgotten and that there was still some
justice to be done
and i don't know i kind of tend to think
that my job with this story is almost
over and then i need to find another
story like this one that or you know
that people aren't paying attention to
you know
i think you know it's been like three
years four and a half since i took it up
so i kind of think that maybe it's time
for me to let other people take up that
you know we'll be talking about this
like the jfk assassination there will be
documentaries going on well after we're
all gone about who killed jeffrey
epstein that's my thought
okay thank you
my basic question is
do you think that jeffrey epstein was
blackmailing leslie
wexner who's the head of the limited and
how did epstein push out harold levin
the former money manager for
wexner bexner
you know when i did this series um i had
you know there was so many angles to
this case you know all the powerful
people that he knew and um you know how
did he get his money and um you know
there was just all these rabbit holes
that i could have you know jumped down
and um
i had to at some point sort of define
the story and
do you know a certain piece of it
because there was no way i could do at
all and so i didn't really look into
that part of it to be honest with you i
mean now we know a lot more about
that um you know all his connections and
all the people that he probably had the
goods on so to speak and certainly
wexner is in that category uh you know
he he wexner has already been on the
record as saying that epstein's stole
millions of dollars from him he never
reported it
why do you not report it you don't
report it because epstein has something
on you and it's it's you know what he
has is is far more damaging than you
know the whatever it is the 50 million
that he stole from me so he you know
epstein also was very good at making
people
feel that he had something on them where
or that he had you know connections you
know i don't know how deep his
connections were to some of these people
but because he had
or he talked about it or he had
photographs of him with all these people
and all these people allowed him
themselves to be with him it gave him
some credibility that he probably
wouldn't otherwise have had if he was
just a regular you know
multi-millionaire but he used these
people to some degree to give himself
you know leverage over even more
important people
so he was a good con man so it's hard to
know how much he really the how much
dirt he really had versus how much he
led people to believe that he had
julie first i just want to thank you for
being such an inspiration to young
journalists
shorter than the guy before me
you are truly an inspiration and my
question for you the part of the book
that i just loved so much was you know
the challenges of being an investigative
reporter here you have this amazing
story and still you're pulling teeth uh
to get the article written so
in in light of where we are today with
newspapers do you have thoughts on
structural changes or foundational
changes in the news business
that could help save
newspapers large and small through
throughout the country
oh gosh if i knew the solution to that
man
i'd probably win a pulitzer prize for
that um
you know it is such a tough battle
because our attention is just focused so
many other places now with the you know
the internet and social media and
everything it is absolutely crazy i i
don't know really what the answer is i
you know the only thing i can say is i
think people still want to read
good stories and good journalism
and
i don't think that'll ever go away you
still need the content you know you
might get the headline by turning on
your tv but you're really not going to
get a good story out of it and you know
of course all all of you are here
because you're you're readers you know
so you probably i'm i'm preaching to the
choir here you probably all understand
all that but there's a whole
another part of our world that of people
that just don't you know they don't read
they really don't they just turn on you
know tv
and they hear something
from sean hannity and they think that
that's all based on fact and that's all
a story uh or
you know anderson cooper whoever
your persuasion is but it it goes both
ways i mean this is a world where i
think our education system really has to
do a better job i think that that's
where it starts you know with our
education system and
thanks
hello
hi i dabbled with the herald a few years
back so it's nice to see another
reporter
um
so
i'm kind of curiously have you ever seen
any of the uh
versions of the epstein story that have
been adapted to popular uh television
shows like say law and orders version of
it and what your opinion of theirs is
no
i've never seen it i don't really watch
a whole lot of tv i really you know i'm
kind of i'd have forced myself sometimes
to watch certain things that are news
related because i know that i should
watch them but i'm just not a good tv
watcher i think i have a short attention
span
hi julie um
thank you
hope there's no oh there's no one else
um
i wanted to ask about
how you navigated
the controversy of the story and in
particular the fact that
there are a lot of
conspiratorial
theories going around about it because
it seems like
discussing whether or not uh epstein
killed himself is sometimes equated with
discussing whether or not he was a
government agent or discussing whether
or not the clintons did it or anything
like that so um how do you navigate that
kind of
controversy and how are you able to
pursue
the right sources when there are so many
competing theories out there
well i i think it's important to
you know whenever you do a story as a
journalist you have to make sure that
you have some facts to back it up and so
when some of these stories come
you know come up one of the you know
these conspiracy theories
you just go to people like an expert
that knows about the bones in the neck
you know like i interviewed michael
baden who i have a lot of respect for
he's a
really um well-known forensic
pathologist and he was president
epstein's autopsy and i i've worked with
him for years on
the deaths that i covered in the prison
system and he explained in very clear
detail about why he didn't feel epstein
committed suicide so and i have a lot
like i said
and also have a lot of experience
covering crimes and just common sense
things didn't happen in this case that
would happen you have to treat this as a
potential crime scene from the very
beginning because you can't go back and
collect the evidence after it's all gone
you know and they didn't do that and i
know that these uh officers in this
system are trained to do that you know
and so
you know i guess really the the short
answer to this is that you have to
use uh real experts and real facts uh
you know i don't think you should ignore
ex conspiracy theories but once you find
like two problems wrong with it you can
pretty much figure that it's a you know
it's not true
thank you
i just i just really wanted to add there
um
you know julie really does spend a lot
of time in the book
talking about all the work that goes
into this all the records we talked
about it during this conversation
um
there are theories and there is deep
reporting um that is backed up and then
lawyers review everything before this
published and you know julie and i
talked a lot about and it's very much in
the book how
many people don't understand the process
and and what
these stories go through
to even get published
though yeah i i one of the reasons why i
really didn't set out to write a book
about journalism or about me especially
not me
but my editor kept saying
you know
like i would write something and she
would say well but how did you do that
i'm like i don't know i just did it well
you need to explain how you did that and
uh so
you know you don't think as a journalist
how you do something you kind of just do
it i guess all of you probably have
careers or jobs where if somebody right
now told you how how do you do that
explain to me every detail you probably
couldn't do it right away probably would
really have to think about it
and as i started thinking about it and
adding some of that in the book it
occurred to me that a lot of people
don't understand
the you know the work that goes into
investigative journalism and and the
sacrifices that you really make you know
in time and money and then
um you know so i thought in a way that
maybe it would be good to find to get
that in into the public eye so that they
understood
um you know just the struggle
um thank you so much for your uh work
with this spoke and your courage and
your persistence i'm sure it took a lot
of that and
you know um the conspiracy and just this
creature that was jeffrey epstein and
whether or not he took his own life i i
feel like a bigger story is even the
perversion of justice right and i'm
curious to know if there's any
way of taking it forward you know so
it's not just another slap slap on the
hand but policy change or what might
happen from here yeah that's a very good
question i'm glad you asked it because
that was the whole reason
really why i did this story because i
don't think
i didn't think that
that the coverage of this case
um did enough um
to explain
the broken system of justice we have in
this country
and
i i i think i just was actually in an
interview right before this where where
i was asked a similar question and
my answer was i'm hopeful
that
you know the younger generation of
people in our system you know police
officers lawyers prosecutors fbi agents
um
understand how our system has been
broken for so long and work on fixing it
you know i'm hopeful that there you know
that that a younger generation
um will do more now that we know we have
so much more information you know
cameras are out there everywhere we know
now about the the
the level of police brutality
particularly involving people who are of
color people who are poor we now know
that you know there was a long time ago
when i started journalism that whatever
a police officer said you would just
take his gospel and you would write it
now we don't do that as much anymore we
know that it's not always
the way it happened so we'll go out and
we will now interview other witnesses
and we will get different stories so i
think that that has come because our
society is changing we're starting to
finally understand that um we need to do
you know we need to do a lot to fix our
criminal justice system
and make it fairer and make it more just
for everybody because these girls were
poor girls i mean one of them told me
you know the reason why jeffrey epstein
picked
somebody that he thought nobody would
listen to and he was right
he picked these girls because he felt
nobody would believe them and you know
that's part of what is going on in our
country and we have to i hope you know
that that it changes and then our
younger generation will you know
look at things differently
can you talk about his surveillance
system how extensive it was
what
he had on it
and what you think happened to it
well he had
cameras and practically i mean he had a
whole room in his new york mansion of
cameras and as i understand it from
people who were there
he had cameras almost in every room
and there's been an awful lot of
speculation about what would have
happened to that film now remember when
this crime first happened in 2005 2006
technology was not what it is today so
whatever kind of footage he probably had
from back then god knows what kind of
shape it was in i mean i've had quite a
few people come to me with uh here's
this i you know claiming that they had
jeffrey epstein video footage and it's
so grainy that there's no way you could
tell who's in the who's in the footage
so you know we really don't know if he
if he really had any even if he was
taping people we don't know if the
footage is exists still or it's even
usable um so it's hard to know exactly
what kind of condition that stuff would
be in and certainly
if it existed the fbi has it and
my feeling is if they did get anything
like that they're going to bury it and
it's not going to come out
uh oh we have time for one more question
one more question okay
um i've found in my reporting that
sometimes the line blurs between being a
journalist and almost a therapist to
your source and i can imagine that being
especially true with these girls who'd
been or these women now who'd been so
traumatized when they were young and no
one had ever believed them
how did you win their trust how did you
approach them as subjects for this
reporting
well i did some homework beforehand
because i knew that this was going to
this had a good chance of
re-traumatizing them and i didn't want
to do that i had i had a lot of
experience interviewing crime victims
any i had even interviewed rape victims
before but these were victims who had
been abused when they were very young
and so i
you know i interviewed um you know
people who work with those kinds of
trauma victims uh to try to get a handle
on how best to approach it i think
ultimately what emily and i did was we
just let them talk
we didn't really
you know what happened next you know
tell me that tell me that we didn't have
to because once they started talking
it just spilled right out they had been
waiting
too long to tell that story and you know
i described the first victim who i got
teary about before and and
you know that interview was incredibly
i mean it was so emotional and powerful
and i just swallowed my pain you know
that you see me now i just like you
swallow it when you're you know you
don't you know show emotions you just
keep going and it wasn't until i got in
the car and she called me and thanked me
that i i did i cried i broke down you
know because i knew that
we had such a responsibility to tell
this story in in a respectful way i felt
a lot of pressure at that moment you
know and hoped
um
you know just hoped that i would do them
justice you know
uh julie i think it would be really
great if you just closed reading from
the preface
page
14.
[Music]
the jeffrey epstein story epitomizes our
nation's lopsided system of justice
and how victims of sexual assault
especially those who are young and poor
are discarded shamed and mistreated by
the very people who are supposed to
protect them
epstein got away with his crimes because
nearly every element of society allowed
him to get away with him
professional legal and moral ethics were
set aside for a broken system of values
that places corporate profits
personal wealth
political connections and celebrity
above some of the most sacred tenets of
our faiths our teachings and our
democracy
when i became a journalist i learned
that the most rewarding part of my work
was in writing injustices for those who
could not fight for themselves
few people seem to recognize that
epstein not only beat the system but he
was probably still hunting terrorizing
and abusing young women and girls
i would face many obstacles on my path
to the truth
i would be attacked by the legal forces
who failed their solemn oaths
by the defense attorneys who profited
off of death off of epstein's crimes and
by some of those within my own industry
who thought that what i was doing was
nothing more than a rehash
of an old story
in my lifetime there has never been a
more urgent need for journalism or a
more important time to play a role in
giving voice to those who have none
i believe that at this moment in history
when world events test our resilience
and when propaganda conspiracies and
lies threaten to undermine
all that our nation holds dear it will
be journalists who hold the corrupt and
powerful to account
as journalists we cannot put aside this
important mission even if we think the
story has already been told
because this was one story that wasn't
finished
so thank you julie and karen and good
night
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
and that wraps up our coverage of the
miami book fair you can watch all of
today's programs at any time by visiting
our website booktv.org and clicking the
book fairs and festivals tab
weekends on c-span 2 are an intellectual
feast every saturday